[Musik]
viel spaß wie hin und weg wünscht ihnen
duckte weltkrieg ich bin doch kein
vielen dank dass sie das auch sagen da
bin ich gar nichts passiert so renz
halle berry von griechenland oder vor um
die halbe welt reisen
[Musik]
zeltweg
si
[Musik]
die kalorien
mit katja und neuseeland sexleben auf
den ersten blick im revier ferien muss
mai - der schweiz rund und das meer vor
der haustür mit gewöhnt ist
aber fügt ich wirklich einen entspannten
tag lang fachfrau in torgau server
pickel händler mit mori wurzel tötet ein
freier tag doch canaria ist bevor warnte
bauer kommt es oft vor dass ihr tage für
euch allein nicht so oft ohne maria
eigentlich nie wir haben keine
verwandten oder wo wir wohnen so ist sie
eben mit uns zusammen
es wäre natürlich schön finden zu
großeltern da wären die seele
[Musik]
hemminger wenn man mit einer frau vom
anderen ende der welt zusammen ist gibt
es immer pro und contra die vorteile man
kann in die schweiz gehen und vroni und
raclette essen
der nachteil man muss 24 stunden fliegen
um überhaupt dahin zu kommen
nein ernsthaft es ist sicher schwieriger
aber wenn man jemanden liebt findet man
immer lösungen auch wenn es mal
schwierigkeiten gab wir sind immer noch
hier und es klappt
wir bleiben dran
[Gelächter]
egal was macht eigentlich frauen
die surf und frauen sind traditionell
eher ich für falsch
es gibt so kommentar von den kollegen
oder was ihre kollegin gerade kommentar
abgeben
sabine schweizer kollegen oder
kolleginnen hätten schon job und auf den
job kontert und einfach mal machen will
und bin dauernd neuseeland ich gleich
recht anders in der schweiz finde ich
jetzt als am morgen und übermorgen ja
ich werde werde ich mehr oder wird nur
wie hat man ihr nicht vor dem lande
das land das im gold sich immer noch ist
obwohl ich doch lieber nehme ich mir das
mal sehen ich bin ja das tut in einem
land wie der schweiz eine schwierige
vorstellung so viel in das diskutieren
wir gerade nicht für immer aber für eine
gewisse zeit
ich war in der schweiz ist schön da aber
für immer das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen
und dann wischt sehr bedürfen katja es
braucht kompromiss wenn sich zwei so
gern nennt wird katja und lgs
verschiedene welt rühmen dass sie für
immer in chelsea
das wies aber duchs neuseeland oder in
der schweiz gefragt wird sie wieder weg
das leben lang begleiten
war
[Musik]
für mich ist es die zum adac und danke
für den kreisläufer der welt
[Musik]
im moment ist das wirklich das und ich
gesucht haben ist ganz simpel aber nicht
gespielt und das ist das was sie am
schwierigsten war es für sie selber sie
gab die familie und alles auf es
beeindruckte mich dass sie mich
offensichtlich so sehr liebte dass sie
das in kauf nahmen
[Musik]
der freiheit in der brennlinie von
montana hat verspricht ein preis und
david greene ein tag im flat reservat
für zu werden und sie zum durchklicken
und zum nachdenken wieder länger 1000
auf fragen zur zukunft gedanken über die
eigene zukunft und die ihrer tochter evi
und adina die schweiz zurück laut hp und
heim wo immer du bist regelt schwinge 28
jahre definitiv wahrheit sind ihre
töchter 18 und 20
[Musik]
ja endlich es probiert einer woche
kontakt
[Musik]
die havag von hermine schengen steht
aber die sind 18 ich sehe also ich finde
irgendwie ja hier gesprochen
und wenn ich glücklich bin und es stimmt
schon
kann ihre wege wieder sagen dass ich
schweizer bin ich was gefiel russland
das recht schnell falsch interpretiert
die schweizer klubs millionen schweizer
franken fehlen pinola wird gespielt
[Musik]
nein sie unter dem is sind hütt einem
ski und sieht vier york führte die liebe
täter was für sie gerade bis zur gibt im
moment ins monterey nächste gruppe
wurden 15 gewachsen ist nein sie hat
mexiko psychologie studiert demi
scherzte bank layoffs matur gemacht und
bis die beiden worden sind
außerdem ist sie ein ort wo typisch für
mexiko trifft sie haben sind im markt
mit dem große ganze spiele damit sie die
heime kurzerhand zum beispiel cola oder
putzmittel wo man die heimat kommen
brauchen völlig könne man sich am besten
probiert oder so schön
vom junior hatte demis bank allesamt
dazu und krawatten abgestreift hat ihnen
ältere vokabeltraining sie sind die
website und im schlossgut welt entdecken
ich bin zudem zieht buch 30-jährige
wahlkreis nachdem ihr neues modul
abgeschlossen und bin schon eineinhalb
jahre unterwegs sie zurückstoßen wurde
darja klischina von mexiko auf der
pazifischen küste kann ich sehe meinen
klub ganze industrie und visuell so lieb
zu mir
[Musik]
das spiel ist fertig und ich glücklich
für klärte demis böse krämpfe nein sie
erst gar nicht um religiöse nur ihre
telefonnummer hätte können erobere
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe so extreme opfer teilt das das
ego sehr geschadet hat dass sich das
definitiv keine programme noch ein tag
ist sie dann zurück auf andre was vor 20
uhr stunde vor dem feind sind und haben
ihre nachfolger in der forschung sagt
sonst stunden mit dem bus dann nicht
jedes mal wenn ich bin ja bis jetzt
trete so ich bin und mein gott dass ich
ein psychopath werdet nicht
vergewaltigen oder sowas ist das mega
schlimm aber dank sie im song könnt
huster und kurz zu farben auf herzen
ruft für den nc und die ganze familie
gottes dass ich achteinhalb jahre her
und jetzt suchen
doch nein sie im huus 40 38
[Musik]
almost all die menschen die hitze mehr
stimmung aber schon nach fünf minuten
bin ich aus mexiko mehr umarmt und küsst
wurde als die dc-10 region zu buche
für mich ist auf der erste mexiko
besucht das ganz schön schwer
zuerst ist mir aufgefallen dass er
anders ist
ich habe sofort gewusst dass ihr der
ehemann meiner tochter wird warum er hat
mich entzückt verzaubert ich liebe ihn
wie einen so dass die verbundenheit so
typisch hat will ich noch ein anderer
grund betrüger wurde denise vor fünf
jahres zweite mal zu denen sie auf
mexiko ist familie gottes tief
erschüttert derrick der nutzer jährig
brühe de nancy hat sich kurz vorher
bekannt
pension der dort gehört wenn dicke sich
nach der planlose situation sie war sehr
stark was los ist wo man nur zettel aber
auf einem besen den strand und das dass
wir irgendwann alle zusammen
zusammen werden sie erfolg hat jetzt 30
sie sind gerade jetzt wird hier etwas
stark wo es passiert ist und ich glaube
das ist eigentlich schön dass das du
jetzt aber ist dass ihr da sehen wir das
ist ja noch lang ist noch in die stadt
hinein für seine lieblings was taxi tag
vor dem tod hat durch seine depressionen
braucht aber zurück ich habe mich holt
und sie laborierte darf man selbst
letzte war es okay ich habe jetzt so
viel geld auf die seite sondern sie ganz
großen appetit will morgen existiert
oder
[Musik]
sid woran ich mich erinnere dass ich bei
unserem ersten treffen viel gestresster
unverkrampfter war als ich es mir je
vorgestellt
und was ich mir das herz schlage ich
habe das nicht dass nicht auch das ist
ein herz so schnell dass ich mir du bist
das glück sehr aufgeregt ist
[Musik]
der meteorologe thomas kleibl hacken ist
außer sich wenn man zum david und seiner
familie ziert auf der berüchtigten lose
winter weg und ich wohne im
untergeschoss von huchs vor der
schwiegereltern
es erinnert dass peet lehrt
wohnsituation von teenager liaison im
sous soul vom elternhaus oder zu
menschen das gefühl das wird eine
schlacht ist es in richtung stellen will
sich als ich mal kaffee statur für hobby
star neu definieren und so dass ich sage
ich muss sich allerdings erst noch vital
die blöde sache neue jahr fangen aber
das ist aber das warten ist ich habe ich
bisher ab
das ist jetzt mal für ein paar monate
dann sehen wir ob wir eine wohnung
suchen
ach du bist aber mit ein bisschen mehr
tun
[Musik]
barry und sich wohlfühlen zum glück nur
bedingt mit temperatures zur familie von
david p thomas hafner herzlich hoffnung
und das obwohl sie das schweizer huhn
kränker hand wo noch ihren song thomas
es sehr unkompliziert er ist ein
großzügiger und äußerst angenehmer
mensch co2 führen hier ihr eigenes leben
und ich rede ihnen nicht rein
thomas ist herzlich willkommen bei uns
ob sie nun hier bleiben oder eine eigene
wohnung suchen
eigentlich hätte david und der thomas
vorjahr im kleinen rahmen wird aber
familie von dhabi hat andere pläne
und es ist es richtig großes freistoß
wurde
[Musik]
als die zeremonie begann und wir mit der
ganzen familie reinkamen hätte ich mich
am liebsten in luft aufgelöst
mein mund war so trocken meine lippen
klebten an den zähnen macht und dazu als
kanada hoch zieht der verglich schlecht
licher bar inzwischen seien verständlich
das sind sehr schöne erinnerungen
[Musik]
extremer druck machen generell bei dem
hoch sieht man muss sich das mal
vorstellen da hat der autos
unterschiedlicher russland oder wie
viele denken
und nun spielt die familien der kanadier
sind so sind so oft sechs sieben
großmutter die hat erst vor kurzem
erfahren dass ihre ex landesrat mussner
vorstellen wieder die meisten würde ja
werden muss und was sie gemacht hat sich
auf mich zukommt mich zum ersten mal
gesehen als einfach verdrückt und im
ausgewählten david gekommen
[Musik]
grenzenlose wir wie heißt viel zu oft
und viel neueste zur grünen endloses
schneeschuhe zum beispiel wenn in der
heimat so langsam die ersten
schneeglöckchen
[Musik]
es ist ein unterschied ob man frisch
verliebt ist oder ob man verliebt ist in
die person und das ist ganz klar dass
das wissen wir dass der chemie dahinter
steckt wenn man verliebt ist und das ist
meiner ansicht nach wird die iv logisch
dass ab laut dass das die romantiker auf
allen dass dir nachher sicher langsam ja
so etwas wie nachher aber natürlich aber
dass das frischverliebte online geht
aber ohne blumen hast du ein blumen für
mich geschickt keine ahnung
also ich bin nicht bewährt und wird ua
über dem geschenk das so ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im großformat in creidlitz unterfangens
[Musik]
nur sind jüngere bruder adrian halbzeit
kvist wurde martin im oktober 2012
lediglich fisch und vier tage später als
verortete zug schwyz und englisch sind
tatsachen besser unter adrian ist für
martin wahrscheinlich auch nur darum
geweiht wurde
die lehrerin der hochzeit - lehne frage
mikrowelle viel stellt schlussendlich
aber wie in hamburg
vom ersten kontakt bis zur hochzeit
hätte martin und landrat 54 tag braucht
bündner rekord
noch gehofft sie hätte martins eine
ältere sms und es beliefen sich ihre
brut geschickt
familienfeste in der schweiz sind ganz
anders als in russland oder der ukraine
dort ist immer alkohol und spielen und
am schluss singen und musizieren und
tanzen alle der kulturellen unterschied
setzte timo ganz einfach und alkohol hat
sogar für einen moment junge eheglück
von martin und alana bedroht die
wahrheit aber ich bin der meinung dass
meine geschichte perfekt für mich warum
dieser mann nicht zu chronischer weil er
kann nicht er habe keine alkohol janssen
ja das ist das ist für mein charakter
für mein tempo das ist besser man aber
wenn du dann werden wir belogen oder
irgendwie ehemaliger frönen da ist sich
schlag aber als patron gesehen oder
erlebt manchmal der familie war immer
betrunken ist und eben auch viel mehr
lebt wie die menschen trinken sich total
verändern und das ja das finde ich
schade
klien auch der hochzeit islam und wo
ehrenburg der luft war und in jeans
glück perfekt abrede lana ihrem inneren
jetzt zu der zeit an der ostsee sowie
weg für die haie umwelt ohne freunde und
vom schweizer tut als sei überstanden
ich war immer allein
mir wurde das im moment einfach zu viel
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass martin mich
einfach mal in den arm genommen hätte
natürlich habe ich in unter druck
gesetzt habe ausgeworfen
ich habe gesagt ich könne so nicht
weiterleben ich wollte dass er mich
beruhigt sein mitleid zeigt stattdessen
sagte er nur ja und jetzt sollen wir uns
scheiden lassen
und ich sagte 'komm entscheiden er
musste sich sitzen
aber ich war ja angetrunken und meinte
das nicht ernst für mich war das damals
ja nicht so scheidl sie mit dem
breischen die hat wiederum klar die
angst hat dass das ist eventuell nachher
dass sie denn just talking ukraine wo
die darum kämpfen dass der leon nun ja
wieder sein dass in wenigen natürlich
sehen daneben
zudem bezweifle ich vielleicht wieder
habe gebraucht diese situation
frauen haben effekt perfekt trainierte
viel pathos 400 besucher und das ist
schön weil man das gefühl hast dass du
es nur schief geht dann richtig
das macht so automatisch für leben so
dass automatisch machen
das kostet überwindung ich vermisse mein
altes leben nicht mir scheint unser
heutiges leben sehr schön auch wenn mein
bruder von uns gegangen ist was sehr
schwierig war mein bruder war 19 jahre
lang mit mir ich bin dankbar dafür und
konnte ihn gehen lassen
jetzt leben wir einen neuen abschnitt
dem es ist teil unseres lebens geworden
und wir sind jetzt sehr glücklich
[Musik]
nein sie unter dem es führe dass
künstler und fa cup runde lebe sie malt
bilder und verkauft und er produziert
film fürs internet eigentlich ist ganze
liebe für deine 2 ist dieses
gesamtkunstwerk erntehelfer influence
und gelegenheitsarbeiter haug sie sind
mitten an für ihre youtube meint drei
neues video
doch doch er fährt auch lieb mich meine
liebe du hast mich nie fahren und mutter
auch nicht dass ich heute mit regeln das
ist falsch weil ich eine spur
erwachsenen der blickrichtung in mexiko
rollstuhlfahrer linken spur erwachsene
rückzug und eigentlich einzige
westschweizer mexiko keine sichere
autobauer soll jetzt geregelt
[Musik]
nancy unter dem mexiko online-stores
dank ihrer videos über soziale medien
kennzahl bilanz geschichte vom schrägen
schweizer wo sich sehr stehen
mexikanerin und das land verliebt hat
angefangen hat die arbeit als youtube
wie zufällig mit selber gemachte videos
können freunden und familie 3 wähler
zeigen oder sogar mehr sie sind jetzt
wollten auf youtube facebook und
instagram über 100 musik liegt auf einem
monitor job macht und ihre natur
manchmal sorgen wir das gleiche zuerst
sievernich
dann kann ich schneide
[Musik]
ich habe seitdem in die hand und
dringlich überall wo ich weiß nicht was
sie später
[Musik]
oster scheele sinnvoll ausgeflogen
damals so traurig dass ich sterben sagte
ich mir wenn mir mein leben egal ist
du wirst mit dem velo losziehen dann
komme ich mit
egal was passiert
machen wir es iris ziel vor alaska bis
patagonien fahre die musiker kilometern
und alles mit dem wls gemeinsames großes
abenteuer wundern weg zum tor
verarbeiten nach dem tod von bruder neue
sinn im leben finden
wie bekehren
vom fahrzeug gefahren hat sie im herbst
wieder den text
hey ich würde eine schöne mourinho ist
super unterwegs geldes kommen ist die
kalifornische obstplantagen als
hilfsarbeiter geschaffen von mexiko zu
stoppen sind zwei jahre ohne auf dem
velo
okay okay okay du hast was du was
passiert ist dass ich mit meiner dieses
okay okay
nur gut dass du dich dafür ist
entschlossen zurück nach montenegro
sie hat auf ein normaler wie wild wie
sie christa haye wenn ich jetzt mal
sagen sie möchten wählen und das web
dienen und so hat sie so aufgebracht
dass sie sich jetzt einmal gemacht hat
mit ihrer kunst und ich von videos über
rollen mit renault passt ich bin auch
von der abend die reise bekannt sind
videos halten
schlichter zum islam in mexiko auf
einmal und die videos seien davon besser
funktioniert nach mexiko mit strotze
gebäude vor lebensfreude und neuem mut
sowie der über markt
die domänen ist was würdest du nicht für
ihn tun weil es zu gefährlich ist
ich tue das auch für mich ja bei dem ist
riskiert manchmal etwas viel
wurdest du dich ab passt ja ich bin oft
eigensinnig sie und man hier weil der
großteil an oder was mir und ich es auch
nicht teilt und sich die wahlanalyse mit
offenen armen empfängt und was mir ist
schockierend mikas hast du gas und dass
einige bestände und haben wir mit dem
velo unterwegs waren
wurde uns überall geholfen immer haben
alle alles mit uns geteilt
wieso sollen wir nicht auch teilen also
hätte ich mich nicht als es ist ein mega
wichtig würden wir extrem steilen als
1000 trainings grund das war schon eine
große großzügigkeit von dem mexikaner
lernen kleine familie gottes fünfter
straße
für planer aus tussis geht es nur noch
um die ukraine bleibt zum dreh monat
lieber und brigit macht sich parat für
das wichtige indianisches ritual und weg
[Musik]
hinunter präsentiert wurde vor dr